[موسيقى]
كان هدفنا الأكبر هو زيادة مشاركة الإناث
في الولايات المتحدة وفي جميع أنحاء
العالم كان لدينا الكثير من الوقت للجلوس حقًا
وكتابة ما ستكون مهمتنا بالضبط وماذا
استقبلنا مع هذا النادي
، ومن هذا المنطلق الذي تعرفه في
شهور العمل والتخطيط ، تمكنا من
إطلاق
تكنولوجيا (موسيقى) belitech all-female أولاً ، جميع الإناث ،
تأسست في
بودابست في عام 2014
على مدار الوقت الذي نما فيه  وتتفاقم
بفعل قوة وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي والعديد
من الرياضيين البارزين الذين يمارسون الرياضة في
جميع أنحاء
العالم لدرجة أن نجمنا الشمالي
الآن سيكون رياضة أولمبية
بحلول عام 2028 كجزء من بيان المهمة الذي
أطلقناه هنا في لوس أنجلوس
وعالميًا أيضًا حيث لدينا
اتحادات الكرة التقنية الوطنية في جميع
أنحاء العالم أه
اعتبارًا من اليوم ونوادي فنية بشكل أساسي
عبر الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
أعتقد تمامًا أنه
ملعب متساوٍ فالكرة أخف بكثير
لذا  لقد كان من الضروري لمسه لكي تعرف أن الحصول على
ضربة قوية يتطلب طاقة أقل في الواقع ،
يتعلق الأمر كثيرًا بالتقنية ، لذلك
أعتقد أن طبيعة
كيفية فيزياء الكرة
وكيف تكون منحنية ،
كل هذه المكونات المختلفة تخلق
تحديات أعتقد
يساوي
حقًا الكرة التي أحبها لأنها أولاً وقبل كل
شيء
مجرد لعبة حيث يتعين عليك استخدام
عقلك والتفكير قليلاً ، لذا فأنت
تفكر في أصابع قدميك
وتوضح حقًا أسلوبك
والشيء الآخر الذي  إن حب
كرة التكنولوجيا هو أنك قادر على التنافس
مع
الرجال ، لذا فهي ساحة لعب
متساوية ونأمل
أنه من خلال تقنية الفقاعة ، يمكننا إشراك المزيد من
النساء
والتنافس مع الرجال ، وهذا الشيء العظيم في
هذه الرياضة هو أنه
يمكنك  التنافس ضد رجلين
، ذكر وأنثى ، يمكنك أن تكون فريقًا نسائيًا بالكامل ،
ويمكنك أن تكون فريقًا من الذكور
والإناث ، وهذا هو نوع من خلق
المزيد من الفرص التي أعتقدها للأشخاص
داخل الرياضة
[الموسيقى]
التي نريدها  إن موجة
حقبة جديدة من الرياضة تأتي إلى الولايات المتحدة ،
إنها ناشئة وتنمو
مثل
آه وتنتشر مثل والاس
بالفعل ونحن ننمو الأندية
في كل ولاية نحاول الوصول إليها في
جميع الولايات الخمسين  تعرف أنها جزء
رائع منك تعرف الأشخاص الذين
يلعبون كرة القدم حتى لو لم تلعب
كرة القدم ، فأنت تريد أن ترى المزيد من الإناث
يشاركن على هذه المنصة